- [Voiceover] So we have an
interesting equation here.
Let's see if we can solve for k,
and we're going to assume
that m is greater than zero.
Like always, pause the video.
Try it out on your own, and
then I will do it with you.
All right, let's work
on this a little bit.
So you can imagine that the key to this
is to simplify it using our knowledge
of exponent properties,
and there's a couple of
ways to think about it.
First, we can look at this
rational expression here,
m to the 7/9 power divided
by m to the 1/3 power.
And the key realization here is that
if I have x to the a
over x to the b, that
this is going to be equal
to x to the a minus b power.
And actually comes
straight out of the notion
that x to the a over x to the b,
x to the a over x to the b,
is the same thing as x to the a
times one over x to the b,
which is the same thing
as x to the a times...
One over x to the b, that's the same thing
as x to the negative b,
which is going to be the same thing as...
If I have a base to one exponent times
the same base to another exponent,
that's the same thing as that base
to the sum of the
exponents, a plus negative b
which is just gonna be a minus b.
So, we got to the same place.
So, we can re-write this as...
So, we can re-write this
part as being equal to
m to the 7/9 power
minus 1/3 power is equal to,
is equal to m to the k over nine.
And I think you see where this is going.
What is 7/9 minus 1/3?
Well, 1/3 is the same thing,
if we want to have a common denominator,
1/3 is the same thing as 3/9.
So, I can re-write this as 3/9.
So 7/9 minus 3/9 is going to be 4/9.
So, this is the same thing as m to the...
M to the 4/9 power
is going to be equal to
m to the k-ninths power.
So, 4/9 must be the
same thing as k-ninths.
So, we can say 4/9 is equal to k-ninths.
Four over nine is equal to k over nine,
which tells us that k
must be equal to four,
and we're all done.